bourges aux portes de la banqueroute
comment pourquoi une ville de cette
envergure peut-elle perdre l'équilibré
charge de plus en plus lourdes baisses
des dotations de l'état
de nombreuses trésorerie municipale sont
en alerte prescilla à 20 ans elle fait
partie de ces 6 % de français qui
déclarent avoir été victimes d'un
système
elle a brisé le silence et se bat pour
se reconstruire
comment s'en sortir après un tel choc
physique et psychologique nous
apporteront des éléments de réponse
uber un mot qui fait désormais partie de
notre langage
un combat entre l'entreprise
traditionnelle et sa rivale numérique
taxi vtc n'est pas seulement d'autres
domaines sont touchés par cette pratique
rituelle enquête au centre c'est
mercredi 2 mars après votre soir 3